[Music]
say anytime you're talking to your phone
that's pretty much a neural net doing
that it does really well an image
recognition autonomous cars come in soon
the top flight method for genetic
sequence saying is the neural network
you can say they're loosely inspired by
the frame it is a network of neurons
people call it neurons
they're all connected to each other
going down through the layers in a way
they mimic neurons and that there's
little triggers each neuron has kind of
threshold called a weights where it
makes their decisions so it takes in
data could be huge amount images and
then once the network is trained you can
put one image in at the front they fire
when they see the thing that they want
to see so you get this kind of cascade
moving through the neural network and
that does really importantly he's just
adorable
but this little magic trick called back
propagation and this is very unbiased
don't do this at all but at the end
you're like okay well you were wrong but
here's the proper picture of a dog and
now you send all that informations back
through the network again and the
network learns just a little bit better
how to say oh this is a dog it's elegant
map and really the breakthroughs in the
field were when they stop trying to be
so biological in the 1980s at the time
they didn't work that great but turned
out all they needed was a huge amount of
processing power and the huge amount of
examples and they was really sing so in
many of these cases accuracy is enough
but when you're talking really life and
death decisions driving autonomous car
making medical diagnosis or pushing the
frontiers of science to understand why a
discovery was made you really need to
know what the AI is thinking not just
what his results are since you have all
these layers it just engages in such
complex decision-making that it just is
essentially a black box we don't really
understand how they think all it's not
lost
this black box problem people are
actually trying to solve this now
through a variety of different ways one
researcher is create a toolkit to get at
the activation of individual neurons in
Network the toolkit works by taking this
individual neuron and telling the
network's to go back and find all the
weights that really make that neuron
just fire like crazy keep doing this
thousands of times and you can see the
kind of perfect input for this neuron
then looking inside these layers you
could see that some neurons learn these
really complex abstract ideas like a
face detector something that can detect
any human face no matter what it looks
like it's not a property you would
expect an individual neuron to have most
don't but some do many neural net
researchers think of it this way you can
think of the decision making of a neural
nets kind of terrain of valleys and
Peaks and the ball represents this piece
of data so you can understand this one
decision that was made in one Valley but
all those other values you have no idea
what's going on so one way to get at
what in AI is thinking is to find a
proxy for what it's thinking so one
professor has taken the video game
Frogger and trained an AI to play the
game extremely well that's fairly easy
to do now but you know what
what is it deciding to do it's really
hard to know they're saying a sequence
of decisions in a dynamic environment of
that so rather than trying to get the AI
itself to explain itself he asked people
to play the video game and have to say
what they were doing as they were
playing it and look for the state of the
frog at the same time and then he found
a way to use neural networks to
translate those two languages the code
of the game and what they were saying
then he imported that back to the game
playing Network
so then network was armed with these
human insights so as the Frog is waiting
for a car to go by you'll say oh I'm
waiting for a hole to open up before I
go or it can get stuck on the side of
the screen and it would say ah Jesus is
really hard and curse so it's kind of
lashing human decision-making it onto
this network with more deep networks
it's all about trust if you have a
result you don't understand why made
that decision how can you really advance
in your research you really need to know
that there's not some spurious detail
that's throwing things all off
models are just getting larger and more
complex and I don't think anyone thinks
they'll get to a global understanding of
what a neural network is thinking any
time soon so if we can get a liver of
this understanding science can really
push forward and these neural networks
can really play
[Music]